when I wake up in the morning there's a
couple of things I do one of them
however every morning is read what is on
the mmq be on my Twitter machine and the
editor and the man behind the mm QB
joins us now on the telephone here on
the Rich Eisen show hello Peter King
good morning sir how are you so nice of
you to say Andrew thank you very much I
appreciate that well it is true and some
people make things up this one I am NOT
help me Peter make make sense of what we
saw last night from the bengals and and
i guess what does mike brown do about it
well i think that part of the problem
here is that the cincinnati bengals a
couple of years ago picked two young
tackles in the draft in the first and
second rounds and everybody said well
bengals got their tackles for the next
ten years they don't have to resign
Whitworth well with the combo platter of
youth of losing Whitworth and Zeidler
and free agency particularly Whitworth
in my opinion is really killing this
team you know I think one of the things
that Andy Dalton could rely on in the
last couple of years I mean in Whitworth
was hurt some but the one of the things
he could rely on in the last couple of
years is a clean left side you know when
he when he went back to pass or when he
was in shotgun and so to me that is not
on marvin lewis that's not on Andy
Dalton that's on the front office for
letting Andrew Whitworth go and at least
it appears now overrating what they had
in house to replace them that's number
one and you asked about what will Mike
Brown do Mike Brown is not one of those
guys who normally is going to be very
aggressive in replacing a coach during
the season just doesn't like to do it
nobody really likes to do it but some
teams will do it if they think it will
help you know I would assume it would be
paul gunter if and when they ever do
anything but I really would be surprised
knowing Mike Brown
history if he got rid of Marvin Lewis
unless it just became absolutely like
I'm talking about Owen age or something
like that which I really don't see
happening the defense is good and it was
good last night and when they get
vantes Burfict back you know I would
assume that they're going to be a very
very competitive NFL defense as they
were last night and so I just I don't
see them going on a long losing streak I
don't see them being great but I don't
think they'll go on a real loan losing
streak well they got to go to Green Bay
this week knowing we're next row it'll
be three in a row correct it'll be three
in a row then they get the Browns I you
know I think the Browns are good enough
to beat them but who knows no one's chok
chok on up wins already to the Browns
but I listen I I hear you the the
Bengals don't fire people Peter it just
seemed last night and and my phone is
blowing up from friends where Bengals
fans granted fans that's the key word
there that that's something that this
feels different that that that felt like
rock bottom for this group well I mean
again I'll go back to the decisions that
were made in free agency and you know I
would ask what actually would be
accomplished in whacking Marvin Lewis
and going with AJ McCarron I mean look I
like AJ McCarron a lot and I think he
might be better than Andy Dalton but I
doubt sincerely that AJ McCarron would
have done a significantly better job I
do agree with AJ Green post-game who
said that this is a you know playmakers
League and the Bengals have done a bad
job in getting the ball in the hands of
their playmakers and that's one of the
things that without any question right
now that when they go back to work and
get ready for Green Bay they've got to
find a way even in double coverage
consistently which is what he's going to
have they got to find a way to get the
ball to AJ Green Peter King joins us
from the MQB I'm Andrew Siciliano
sitting in for Rich Eisen in
the Annapolis Peter this morning where
it is Jacobi Brissette is going to be
the quarterback Sunday when a good
friend Bruce Arians comes to town with
his Cardinals also at Owen 1 do you get
any feeling peter that luck is at
anywhere close to returning you know
I've said the same thing for like the
last three weeks that when I was in camp
in the middle of August I got the
distinct impression that he probably was
gonna miss one or two games maybe three
on the outside I mean I would just say
this if he's not practicing next week
then this is worse than they thought and
the road is going to be longer than they
thought I don't buy the oh we've got to
get Andrew Luck mentally right I don't
buy that uh you know that kind of stuff
that you've you've heard out of
Indianapolis from some people but I do
think that you know their intentions are
absolutely correct and that is that look
we don't want this to be a recurring
problem so until our doctors tell us
that Andrew Luck is absolutely ready to
play football he's not gonna play
football I was under the distinct
impression in the middle of August that
was about a month away but you know
we'll see but I do think if he's not
practicing by next week then all of a
sudden I think the red flag needs to be
raised and can we agree you and I that
any talk of of somehow moving him is
asinine
well you know look anytime anybody talks
about trading either by passing a
franchise quarterback for draft choices
or trading an existing franchise type
quarterback which a Andrew Luck is
certainly I would just remind everybody
to look at the Rams trade when they
traded the second pick in the draft when
the top two picks were going to be
Andrew Luck in RG three and I would just
ask you what actually did the Rams get
from that
the Rams I mean look it's one of the
reasons why less need was under fire
obviously that they didn't make much at
all of those pics relative to what they
should have made and so I I would never
ever ever trade a quarterback who I
thought was potentially a great
quarterback there is no price that is
worth that Peter King from the MQB Peter
forget about the negative here cuz I
think I'm dwelling on the negative here
what what surprised you in a good way
week one cuz I feel like going into week
one you think you know but you truly
never do know about any of these teams
three things number one the ability to
throw the ball deep from Alex Smith I
saw it in training camp Andy Reid told
me after the game for my podcast that
this is what in Alex Smith has been
focused on the entire offseason number
two the resuscitation ability of Sean
McVeigh to get the Rams to not only be
competent but for people to say this is
precisely the way this team was
constructed great defense and play good
enough on offense to win games in the
teens and 20s that's what it looks like
they're on the way to doing but again
you don't want to over eat one game but
I think that was a vital vital thing and
I think number three
Trevor Simeon I think everybody has all
has said consistently about the Broncos
look they're going to have to win in
spite of their quarterback but Trevor
Simeon made some big throws in that game
and I'll give you a four and it'll be
Jacksonville's offensive line and
offensive line coach Pat celerity to
hold the and I think they did this in a
really really smart way watch the tape
of the game and I watched it and I know
I'm here because of NFL game pass but I
watched it on on NFL game pass on Monday
and the way that their offensive line
play
basically they were had such narrow
spacing between their guys and they said
in order to get through us you're gonna
have to physically knock one of us says
you're not going to be able to slither
between us in a three technique kind of
way you're gonna have to physically beat
us up to take to get to our quarterback
I think was a brilliant way to play last
week so those were four takeaways in a
positive Ain that that I liked all right
we're gonna get the game pass I promise
good job by the way working that in
through Pro I but I promise also that I
would ask a Kaepernick question just
real quick yeah is there anything out
there I mean I thought by now there'd be
an injury there'd be something I somehow
he would be on a roster but we're not
anywhere closer are we well I don't know
we haven't had a big injury right a
quarterback yet so we'll see I mean it's
gonna take somebody who's gonna have to
have the guts and understand that he's
gonna alienate a good portion of his fan
base now he's also going to be described
as heroic by another part of his fan
base too so I think that is one thing
that is not you know as we consider this
that people kind of forget but I still
think he's gonna be fine when there's a
big injury Andrew yeah I do too because
he simply is the the best guy out there
and there's no one even close right now
I don't care if people want to say he's
not a system fit he's this he's that he
is the best guy on the street period now
III only I've said this I said you you
tell me if Russell Wilson goes down
Sunday who do you want to play the last
14 games Austin Davis or Colin
Kaepernick that's I mean that's the only
question you ask
I mean it's and and I I've asked it over
and over again but you don't really find
that out until you start playing your
backup quarterbacks which is what makes
the Colts look so dumb you know with
going with Cozine versus you know
signing Kaepernick in the offseason I
mean it but they're not the only ones
there there's 15 of those teams and I
issue a blanket statement basically
saying that you know
this should be about winning football
games and you and you know what if
you're in the position is an owner a
coach and a GM in this league to try to
put the best team on the field to try to
win games and you don't do that and you
have other guys who have no business
being in the same sentence with Colin
Kaepernick and you know you got to be
willing to take some heat you just do
and that's the problem that I see with
this Kaepernick situation and he's still
watching from home and if he is watching
at home he could watch Peter of course
on NFL game pass which you mentioned
earlier i watch games this week on my
iPad as well tell me about it to me what
saves me in my job is these condensed
games that you get when you watch NFL
game pass now you can also watch live
games and all that you can watch them a
coaches tape but you know my time is
fairly precious Monday Tuesday Wednesday
and so I watched three abridged games
this week that I really wanted to see
how did Jackson they'll do it how to Pat
clarity do it on that offensive line
that really really helped me when you
can just watch in an hour instead of
taking three hours it's huge then I
think the other part of this that really
helps me a lot is it allows me to do my
homework from two and three and four
years ago they have old games going back
to 2009
I can watch every game that Colin
Kaepernick ever played and it's just
it's to me is a research tool it is
absolutely totally invaluable and I just
I I love it I'm so yeah we're so lucky
at the mmq b to have gotten this
partnership with NFL game past because
it allows us really to spread the gospel
of something we use at the site yeah I
love it I mentioned it as well I'm not
just saying this because I work there I
do use it all the time and you can watch
the old 22 you can watch any angle you
want you can watch the old games it is
that easy to use it I mean it takes you
three seconds to go from the game you're
watching to another game so it's great
NFL game pass nfl.com slash game pass
Peter King of course from the mmq b the
mmq be calm get the website right and
follow it on Twitter
well thank you sir as always enjoy your
football this weekend
thanks very much Andrew have a great day
you too Peter King everybody the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our app don't have any
memory on your phone let's start to
delete some of those slo-mo videos you
have and you know which ones I'm talking
about